hello everyone and welcome back to the
Sinquefield cup I'm Jennifer Shehadeh
and I'm here with a very special guest
in studio Mary Pillsbury of the Mary
Pillsbury fine jewelry company and
you're also a supporter of the st. Louis
Chess Club in our campus tell us how you
got involved with us well about five
years ago when you had your very first
gala at Saks Fifth Avenue I met you
there and also I wanted to say that I
think it is fantastic
what is going on in st. Louis with Rex
Infeld trying to get elevate the game
here and all over the United States and
getting into the schools and everything
you know I have to commend him for what
he's done
oh yeah they've been wonderful I mean
dr. Jeanne and Rex Sinquefield have done
so much and I think some things that
would really be up your alley as well
with bringing more women and girls into
the game and spreading it education wise
and then of course the music aspect and
the art aspect over across the street at
the world chess Hall of Fame now you are
the sponsor of tomorrow's event the
winter opera series at the Hall of Fame
tell us about that well since I happened
to be on the board and let's see it was
Lauren Stewart who called and asked if
I'd like to underwrite a concert and I
said I'd love to if it's for the Chess
Club and so I thought I would have Gina
Galati who's actually the founder of
winter opera and also has a magnificent
lyric soprano voice and we're going to
also have Keith Boyer who is the best
tenor in st. Louis chosen by the st.
Louis post-dispatch and they're going to
be singing opera tunes and arias from La
Boheme Madame Butterfly The Barber of
Seville and operettas from the Merry
Widow West Side Story Lynn miserab and
things like that well I can't wait I'll
be there this is a great way I know that
the thing fields really feel that the
Hall of Fame it's not only about chess
related arts
about a general cultural salon that kind
of reminds you of the Royal game even if
there's not that direct reference so I'm
gonna be there I'm really looking
forward to it
Mary you know you and I also played a
chess game yes we did and I hate to
admit 190 countries and for hundreds of
thousands of people that you beat me in
a very very short period of time and I
owe you dinner still so after this is
over we'll discuss when I take you out
to wherever you want my husband died or
you can come out to bow Ciel our place
in the country and we will wine and dine
you and make up for me royally losing
terribly quickly to a genius uh Oh God
thank you so much well you also own a
diamond business can you tell us how you
got into the jewelry and diamond
businesses of course you're wearing some
of your own pieces yes well I actually
started singing in New York City and
I'll get if you ask me about that I'll
tell you something about it but I didn't
have anything to do during the daytime
so what I did was I decided to sell
Indian jewelry into the jewelry stores
on Madison Avenue and and 47th Street
and then the manufacturers that I met
said would you sell our diamonds and our
gold so I was a one-woman wholesale
company singing at night and selling
jewelry during the daytime and then what
happened was I moved back to st. Louis
and I thought well maybe I should just
start my own fine jewelry company so I'm
a jewelry designer oh I see they're
showing some of the pieces that I
designed
so I'm actually wearing a necklace that
I designed it's the married pillsbury
version of a fleur-de-lis and then I
guess you can see the bracelet here that
was in the picture also so we have a
jewelry store here in st. Louis at the
Chateau village and in fact I might as
well bring up all of you all over the
world are invited to my Christmas show
which is December 3rd and everything is
wholesale and we're going to have my
designs and we can design anything for
you we major in engagement rings and
we're gonna have champagne and of course
being a pillsbury we're gonna have
brownies oh well but you're the Pearl
Pillsbury and your name is also not at
just about baked goods but about chess
you have a family connection to Grand
Master Pillsbury Harry Nelson Pillsbury
the the US Champion tell us about that
family connection well it's distant but
we are related all Pillsbury's are
related and he was born in 1872 and he
died very young in 1906 and they say he
was a savant and he also had a
photographic memory and he could play
blindfold and when he was in Moscow he
played 22 people blindfolded and then I
read that he had won the Hastings
competition in 1895 that he beat
everybody at the time and I think it was
US chess champion until he died in 1906
yeah and he actually lived in my city
Philadelphia so it's so heartbreaking to
me that he died so young as you know
such a brilliant talent so many of the
great chess talents of history you know
left us way too too soon now you say you
also have a fantastic memory so maybe
that runs in the pillsbury family I I
think it does because I do have a
photographic and a nota graphic memory
and I'm not dumb so but I was nothing
like him and I love playing chess but I
never played chess except with my father
and I won't say on TV one other famous
person I played in beat in three and a
half hours the only important person
ever played was you oh yes and you
annihilated me so at any rate I've
recover recuperated so we'll have to
have another game well thank you so much
it's always wonderful to see somebody
with such a passion for music our
jewelry and chest to come and support us
it it was wonderful to have you and the
pillsbury legacy we actually talked
about Pillsbury by chance and an opening
that came up yesterday so I thought of
you and now here you are I never know
where I'll pop up literally
so what those of you
those of you who are in the st. Louis
area there are a few remaining tickets
for that concert tomorrow and we might
have some highlights for you if you're
not available tomorrow there's actually
a full schedule of amazing events at the
world chess Hall of Fame it's a great
idea if you look at the Chess Club
calendar and you combine some stuff at
the hall of fame and the Chess Club it
really justifies a trip no matter where
you are in the world more info at winter
opera st. Louis org thank you so much
Mary thank you has been my pleasure